how did Celsius define his scale uh he
took the temperature water freezes at
and said that's zero and they took the
temperature boils at and says that's 100
and a figure 200 was a good amount of
demarcations to make in between the two
right yeah except that's not what he did
really
Celsius never devised nor used the scale
that now bears his name are you kidding
me no Michael I'm not this is the
Swedish town of Uppsala located 70
kilometers north of Stockholm so this is
the house where Celsius lived in 1741 he
was professor of astronomy at Uppsala
University and this is the first ever
Celsius thermometer or is it this is the
first scale of onda celsius added onto
or added onto an old the middle
tournament so we have de leus scale on
the left-hand side you know and celsius
is new scale on the right these few
markings show that Celsius came up with
the idea of separating the freezing and
boiling points of water by 100 degrees
he made his first observations with the
scale on Christmas Day 1741 but have you
noticed something strange about this
scale I mean 50 is marked in the middle
but the numbers increased down towards
the bulb of the thermometer so Celsius
had his scale upside down he said zero
degrees at the boiling point of water
and a hundred at the freezing point why
would he do this well for one thing
Celsius was just following the
convention of the other scale on the
thermometer the leal scale also had zero
degrees for the boiling point of water
increasing down to 150 for his freezing
point and a likely reason both of them
used upside-down scales is because they
avoid negative numbers in Sweden it gets
much colder than freezing but never
warmer than boiling water so you don't
have to worry about pesky minus signs
and this helps avoid log book errors I
think it would be really weird if you
had water boiling at zero degrees and
freezing it a hundred
wouldn't that be strange although it
might seem strange today
there is no objectively good reason for
preferring an ascending scale over a
descending one for measuring degrees of
something like hot or cold
in fact when Celsius died of
tuberculosis in 1744 he was still using
this inverted scale so who reversed it
who do we have to thank for the modern
Celsius temperature scale well in 1745
just a year after Celsius is death a new
column appears in the solid temperature
record using the modern scale and at the
top it's got the heading Eckstrom now
Eckstrom was the instrument maker at
Uppsala in 1747 another column is added
with the heading Strummer
who was Celsius as successor as
professor of astronomy again it's got
the same modern scale but it's another
professor at Uppsala who claims that he
reversed the scale that's the famous
biologist Carl Linnaeus he says he
reversed the scale when he ordered a
thermometer from Eckstrom for his
greenhouse whoever it was we know that
by 1745 there was an operational
thermometer at Uppsala University with
the scale that we now all know as the
Celsius temperature scale except this
was not the first such thermometer ever
created in 1743 the year before celsius
died a French scientist working
independently in Leon created a
thermometer with zero degrees at the
freezing point of water and a hundred at
the boiling point his name was Jean
Pierre Kristin so why isn't it called a
degree Kristin instead of a degree
Celsius well for a long time this
temperature scale wasn't referred to
using either of their names and instead
it was just called the centigrade scale
meaning a hundred steps the problem with
this was centigrade has other meanings
in French Spanish and Italian where a
grade specifically refers to one one
hundredth of a right angle so to
eliminate this confusion the
International Bureau of weights and
measures in 1948 decided to rename the
centigrade scale after a scientist
bringing it into alignment with other
temperature scales like Kelvin and
Fahrenheit
they chose Celsius possibly due to a
popular 1800s German chemistry textbook
by a guy named Bruce alias in it
brasilia's identified
is as the first to devise a temperature
scale with zero at water's freezing
point and 100 at its boiling point
propagating the myth that Celsius
created this scale so is Celsius
undeserving of having his name
immortalized on weather maps around the
world well no I mean making two marks
and deciding on a number of degrees in
between them that is the easy part which
others could in this history shows did
do but what Celsius did was he
established which physical processes
could reliably produce a fixed
temperature at the time when he was
working there were some thirty different
temperature scales in use some
thermometers had 18 different scales on
them some more reliable than others for
fixed reference points one scale used
the deepest cellar of the Paris
observatory others used the melting
temperature of butter the internal
temperatures of certain animals or the
hottest day in summer in Italy Syria or
Senegal these dubious scales combined
with inconsistent thermometer
construction made recording accurate
temperatures nearly impossible not to
mention sharing those temperatures with
other scientists elsewhere Celsius
solved this problem in a number of ways
he demonstrated that melting snow
maintains a fixed temperature regardless
of latitude or ambient pressure
he also determined the precise
relationship between boiling point of
water and the ambient pressure so that
thermometers could be calibrated under
any conditions he made it possible to
establish a universal reliable system of
temperature measurement and this is why
Celsius is named is a unit of
temperature even though the scale itself
was not created by him and in fact today
the Celsius scale is no longer defined
by either of waters phase transition
points instead it is based off the
Kelvin scale and that scale is defined
by setting the triple point of water
where solid liquid and gas all exist in
equilibrium at exactly 273.16 Kelvin
this fixes the size of a degree Kelvin
which is exactly the same as the size of
a degree Celsius the zero point of the
Celsius scale is set at 273.15 Kelvin
now what all this means is that today
pure water boils at ninety-nine point
nine seven four degrees Celsius and
freezes at negative zero point zero zero
is
ro1 celsius this precision in a nearly
universal system of temperature
measurement is thanks to a huge number
of scientists so the C after the degree
symbol stands not only for Celsius or
Kristen or Carl Linnaeus but for the
community of scientists whose work over
centuries made a scale so robust that we
take it for granted worse hey I hope you
enjoyed that video I just wanted to talk
to you for a second about patreon as you
probably know patreon is a website where
you can support creators that you like
by pledging a small dollar amount per
month or per video now I have had a
patreon page for a very long time but I
have never promoted it and I have never
accepted any pledges on that page the
reason is because I felt I could never
really offer value through the site
because I was too disorganized and I was
travelling too much but despite that 750
of you have pledged nearly $2,000 a
video and for that I am incredibly
grateful and I want to announce that
starting next video I will be accepting
pledges through patreon and in return I
will be offering some unique rewards to
those patrons and I will also redouble
my efforts to make this YouTube channel
bigger and better than it's ever been
before so if you want to support
veritasium directly you can now do that
via patreon and if you don't want to or
you can't that is totally fine too
frankly I am just very appreciative that
anyone likes watching these videos at
all so now I'm going to go get to work
on making this YouTube channel as good
as it possibly can be and I really want
to thank you for all your support over
the years
and I want to thank you for watching